oh hello welcome to another edition of a
beginner breakdown thank you for joining
me tonight in my a lovely living room
here yes this is how I live yes uh-huh
so here we are with Harper Evan Smith so
if you take a quick look at this
position who do you like here black or
white hopefully the answer is black
Harper had this game against the best
player in Guyana so he could abate the
best player from you gang that would
have been something to put on a resume
okay
beat the best player from Guyana in a
rated
chess tournament but but he had
blackened he was in severe time pressure
six minutes okay he had six minutes left
on his clock that's severe huh okay so
so how would you go about winning this
immaculate position for a black yes I'll
pick a random person from my home yes
Julian Oh interesting okay
so so you notice this Knight is doing a
great job if you ever promote this this
pawn I'll take it okay so all I have to
do is when they when I play it's black
to move here you'll play king of fate
and so now when this King comes we can
we can just us stop it okay and then we
can just get our own we won't play off
six of course we'll play out five and
we'll be a hero okay and then if he ever
comes up like this you know we'll just
ignore it we'd love it get the Queen
we'll take it King takes and now we have
three two two and our King is coming
down to get it but Harper Harper had a
better idea
he's like Knight
you got this you got this and so with
his King
he decided hey I'm gonna go win-win
these pawns and everything's gonna be
great and then Harper went check check
and Harper your idea you better go back
Harper nice girl see you lost and so I
were just gonna everybody can see that
this is a draw so his night really
didn't have the pawn under control so
poor Harper only got a draw out of a
position that the computer deems +48 for
him it's tough to be Harper
here's another game of a Harper Evan
Smith he somehow he he guys raiding up
from like 1600 to 1800 don't ask me how
I wasn't looking and somehow he just
snuck it in there maybe he wrote the
USCF or something I don't know but but
let's see if he really performs like an
1800 in this in this game okay so first
things first pawn to d4 it so far okay
d5 he's playing another one of our
illustrious instructors are Jonathon
shruts okay in this game before Jonathan
worked at the club I believe alright so
c4 c6 good good you don't want to block
in this guy so c6 he's been going to
begin a breakdown I guess so Knight to
c3 Knight f6 you know who hasn't been
going to begin her breakdown
Harper Evan Smith because of course he
plays he plays III but the B'nai
everybody will say huh it's a book move
it's a book move well just cuz it's in a
book doesn't mean it's going everybody
all right so this bishop is now reduced
to shrivel okay let's see let's see if
this Bishop ever does anything good all
right all right so so I guess he just
wanted to like Mike Harper Evan Smith
here I guess he was just being funny
that's the only is that he decide all if
you play a bad move I guess I gotta give
you a little chance Harper okay so
so he boxes in his own Bishop but don't
worry
Harper heaven Smith's gonna remedy all
that for Jonathan he's like Jonathan I'm
sorry dead you're boxed in your guy let
me just take care of that for you okay
so bad idea takes the pawn so now
Jonathan takes back with the e pawn and
now his bishop is free to roam and now
his Bishop is still stuck on the back
row okay all right so he gets Bishop d3
in so he's got to fight for this efore
square here very very important the
square oh and we lost it all right so
here we go so he gets his Bishop out
he'll get his Bishop out Harper castle
so he castles so I kind of kind of doing
the mockery here so Harper decides I
don't want your Bishop going to h3 or
unite so it's a g4 so he plays h3 so
rook e8 attacks the e-file
but pivotal square there so Harper gets
this Queen Bishop in a battery head
toward h7 so Jonathan just keeps piling
the pressure on e4 and eventually it's
gonna crack Knight to d2 Knight to f8
Harper plays a3 preparing the big b4 so
Jonathan's like forget about it a5 that
just puts them in to the shenanigans
so Harper's logo so just play B through
the look at me all right good idea
b3 does nothing a knight to e6 you would
think after b3 after all is dubious
ideas a3 b3 what do you think the
logical move for hope would be right now
yeah Bishop to b2 right that would be
logical I'm not saying it's like the
best idea in the world but it's logical
connect the rooks and steady is low
you'll loop
I just play rook to e1 like double
double blunder let's see if we can see
why rook to e1 an undefended piece is a
bad move
oh because there's a tactic in the
position
yeah Knight takes d4 boom because now he
can't take back or else he loses his
precious rook if he if he takes this
epon off the file Queen comes down and
takes the rook so good idea Harper
alright so that's what happens in the
game and now his Queens under attack so
better move the Queen Queen to b1 and so
let's be a venturous now let's thread
matin to here how can we thread
checkmate in two all right Julian again
Queen e5 threatening Queen check King to
f1 Queen mate because the knight has e
two all to himself
all right so Harper is like oh I'm gonna
take you looking to take you all right
so Queen to h5 now he's like yes I know
I finally get the play Bishop to b2 now
my position is solid okay so Bishop e2
big threat he's threatening pawn takes
Knight I wonder if he's gonna see it he
does all right Knight to f5 and now
Harper is thinking hmm if only I could
activate that Bishop so it's like I'll
just put my knight over in the corner so
now true Bishop attacks the knight but
let's see let's see if it's any good not
really cuz he just comes down and takes
takes the pawn but hey hey your plan
worked
I destroyed your I destroyed your castle
alright and I gave you double isolated
pawns
so Harper spy thinking he's doing pretty
good here oh it's actually a white to
move so he can save the pawn let's see
if he can save it
and so now Harper's like oh I mean he
just can't take it anymore
he just can't take it so that's her
forever and Smith for yeah so that's
1881 right there or whatever so so if
you get paired against in 1800 let's
just say I hope he plays like Harper I
hope he plays like Harper and then who
knows you might be able to be a Class A
player